edgar first of all i'm a longtime fan of
you from a lot
a lot of other projects besides domino
being one of my favorite
um but let's talk about you and let's
talk about this night we're at disney
happiest place on earth
i mean this premiere is huge it almost
feels like we're back to a normal life
where are you at right now how you
feeling yeah well
i i'm very excited i'm very excited very
grateful very grateful that we're
finally here
that that so many people had made such
an effort to be here the fans you know
the effort they made just to just to
show up and be and be here without
supporting us
it's great i'm very happy did you bring
anybody special with you tonight are you
all by yourself read my entire family i
brought my i
i brought my family my mom is here my
dad is here i'm very happy that
my mom is here though i mean it's been a
very hard week for my family
a lot of deaths from covey my
grandmother died
this week so i'm sorry thank you so
so yeah i mean i have to take every
opportunity to invite
people to get vaccinated to trust
science you know to follow
recommendations it is
this is not over you know and and we
shouldn't and a lot of people that's why
i'm saying that a lot of people have
made a huge effort
for us to be here in a safe way but
we're not here yet this
is not i mean this is a huge effort just
for us to be for you to be here for me
to be here
and be safe so i just want i just want
everyone to
to to think about others and also to
to to protect themselves you know and to
protect others and
and we're going to get we're going to
get through this we're going to get
through this and it's and it it
and it will be it'll be a bad and
horrible memory
and we're going to learn from this uh
but we're not we're not at the end of
this yet so we need to be careful
yeah and this is like the perfect moment
in time to realize just how hard it is
to get this many people together
we can rise up as long as we come
together we can make this a reality we
come together we follow we follow
guidelines you know if we really if we
really connect
you know we can we can make it and and
and this movie
this movie i think is the perfect movie
for these times i mean we all
we all want to escape a little bit we
all want to be able to dream
you know of fantastic places you know
and
and and adventure and and and fun and
and humor so i think that
this is a movie that i mean i'm part of
it but as a member of the audience as a
very active member of the audience
i'm very excited to see it yeah edgar
what was your favorite part about
playing this
unique character this unique role what
what did you love most about it
it was it was so much fun because
because the character goes
the character transits all the way from
the most noble intentions to the
to the bitter darkness you know and that
as an actor is always something that
you're grateful
for you know and all of it within the
context of an amazing ride with a lot of
twists and turns and
and easter eggs and surprises and and
a lot of action and a lot of humor so it
was
i mean i grew i grew up watching big
adventure disney movies
and i'm very as a member of the audience
and as an actor i'm so grateful
to always find the humanity in all
disney characters
you